ok
[Musique]
oui
à
bonsoir si chez moi à elancourt
j'invite à dix minutes à pied et en vol
d'oiseau ces deux battements d'aile côté
je suis super contente 1 on est au
prisme pour moi c'est un peu mon
d'olympia
bon ok c'est dans la petite salle la
drogue ça sera pour plus tard vous serez
tous invités si vous payez l'invitation
comme ça je suis ravi d'être là bah
écoutez on fête un anniversaire assez
particulier donc oui c'est mon
anniversaire
applaudissez fait quelque chose c'est
pas vraiment mon anniversaire
aujourd'hui on fait mais 24 ans et 5
mois de célibat
alors on dirait pas comme ça mais oui
j'ai 24 ans j'en ai pas 16 ça vous
surprend
ouais c'est en a surpris plus d'un aussi
haut on dit tu veux boire coins de
l'aude accord parce qu'au cas où si tu
voulais une bière ouais enfin suis super
content de mes messieurs dames tout ça
c'est toute ma vie hanche
alors moi je voulais juste être riche
célèbre claquer des culs sur des yachts
quelque chose de très abordable
évidemment et aussi faire partie pas des
destiny's child par e-mail faut pêcher à
mon fils m'a pas laissé beaucoup je
t'aime le faire de ce côté là aussi le
bègue et du coup je les annoncer à ma
mère quand j'étais petit je lui ai dit
écoute maman c'est sûr je vais être
michel serre pas trop quand je faisais
je vais être michel je prendre sa place
enfin il m'a dit ok je fait inscrire à
la tente
ok vous avez tous pensé au hip hop l'eau
descend machin contretemps tout ça non
j'ai fait de la danse contemporaine et
moderne jazz à elancourt beaucoup
pendant cette année j'ai fait le vent
messieurs dames
alors le budget ils encourent et pas ouf
même si vous payez beaucoup et il avait
mis un ventilateur juste là ouais
j'étais avec un drap et des cannes et je
faisais le vends ma prof de danse est
génial mais elle me parlait quant aux
pies papon fait il tâta tout éclate et
poule et pourtant tu as du talent et
peut-être fait un don pour moi la danse
c'est une autre temps voilà y'a que ça
pendant cette année
cette année plus échanger les éléments
s'étaient l'eau j'ai arrêté j'ai dit non
non non c'est bon pour c'est trop je
suis pas la plus à plaindre hein mon
frère a demandé à ma mère d'être bon il
voulait être footballeur professionnel
il y en a toujours un pour la famille
mais qui termine avec ses potes à faire
un foot salle et à payer pour faire le
futsal d'ailleurs 100 euros une arnaque
le truc ma mère lui a dit inquiète mon
fils j'ai ta carrière bien comment elle
l'a mise à l'école c'est quoi municipal
le conservatoire là il a fait 50 guitare
je comprends toujours pas non plus et
mon autre frère quant à lui alors lui le
pauvre et vous l'êtes rappeur m6 way you
non ma mère lui dit inquiète non figée
ta carrière bien en main
conservatoire cette année clarinette et
là pas plus emballé que ça moi je vous
le dire bon après tout ça toutes ces
expériences pardon ma mère m'a dit bon
maintenant que tu as fais de la danse
battu à faire du chant ouais mais tu es
sûr de ton cou maman parce que bon
moment
t'inquiète je l'état car évidemment bon
ok je te suis bah écoutez je suis parti
avec la municipalité à morzine dans les
alpes pendant deux semaines pour une
colonie spécial chant avec mon frère qui
faisait de la guitare l'autre de la
clarinette le collectif métissé
complètement fait que je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle voulait faire bas à morzine
c'était pas les classes vont plus quoi
moi je pensais que ça allait être
vraiment bien bas les animateurs c'était
pas ça 1
ils nous laissaient sur des marchés
chanter puis ramasser les pièces après
et après aller dans un bar et puis il
buvait puis nous laisser travail
d'enfants on était des roumains
et c'est à cette période là que moi j'ai
lu le livre iqbal ça m'a fait quelque
chose il travaille et d'enfants enfin
bon je me suis dit ils vont peut-être me
donner une musique qui me plaît
l'enfant faire un bref pas de sinsheim
ils m'ont dit jack and mail tu vas voir
un solo et le solo c'est celui ci bon c
est bon pour qu'il est inapte à l'ip et
les macaques oubbana cubana loyer moyen
y est parfois l'esa voilà donc ma
carrière ma fin de carrière prendre
carrière voilà on a fait un spectacle de
fin de deux fins de colonies de vacances
un dans une fromagerie way qui faisait
effectivement aux filles de salle des
fêtes avec 20 personnes que des membres
du staff et ma mère repasse encore la
cassette
ouais encore chaque noël et puis elle
pleure de rire
moi je pleure des larmes de sang
enfin bon j'ai dit à ma mère bon maman
c'est quoi moi je vais prendre ma
carrière en main moi je vais faire rire
les gens m'a dit t'es tu veux faire quoi
baffes qui rigole quoi pourquoi mais
parce que je trouve
ben oui mais fais tes études oui mais
c'est fait à ce effet pas trouvé un
emploi oui mais enfin du coup férir quoi
dit ok bah du coup tu vas être une clown
une saltimbanque une à qui on jette des
pièces comme ça va je voyais pas ça
comme ça mais non enfin oui tu es sûr de
toi
bon oui enfin je crois
bah moi ma fille en tout cas jamais être
à ça jamais jamais avec cette tête là
elle m'a quand même dit je t'ai mis au
monde je peux quand même d'enlever la
vie bon bah comme vous pouvez le voir ce
soir je n'ai pas écouté en est mais en
tout cas je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté c'est ml
[Musique]
bravo mr normal on peut dire que têtu et
l'humoriste de l'étape 1 parce que quand
même tué dans courtoise ouais c'est
humour elancourt avec des gens
bienveillants pour vous mais moi
j'aimerais savoir est-ce que vous avez
aussi une personne de votre entourage
vous a fait cette vanne
oui monsieur vous habitez ou à elancourt
entendus et où vous ne les plaies et mon
père qui sortait pas comme un héros
voilà alors ben brik bateau que tu t'es
lancer dans cette carrière d'humoriste
sa mère est pas là parce que l'on avant
d'être un film à ginasservis dit oui je
m'y oppose alors est-ce que tu aides
actuelles alors oui c'est une actualité
je serai le 5 mars au labo du rire à au
paname et qui se trouve à république je
serai au 7 le 7 mars pardon à lille avec
la troupe arty comédie je serai le 15
mars au wild bill hickok évidemment
jette un max et en français ouais bon
les notes du coup et enfin dont j'ai dit
le 15 mars et ensuite le 2 avril à
mantes-la-ville dans cette suite mais un
peu loin d'ici
eh bien on voit que ta carrière est
lancée merci ma elle vraiment sympa à
voir avec tous merci beaucoup
[Musique]